we're pals so i have seen what your face
looks like i know what you look like but
whenever you perform
you do not like to show your face and i
think people
don't understand why so explain that
first well i was just it's so that i can
go to target and buy a hose if i want to
and or if i'm in a very in need of a
restroom and i can't find one i could go
by the side of the road
nobody would be following me with a
camera trying to get the shot
[Music]
ah yeah i'm so excited for today's
lesson
because we're learning with one of my
favorite singers sia
so we're going to look at a couple
interviews with her and then we'll learn
with a couple of her popular songs and
if you just want one
or the other then you can skip to
whatever part you want using the
chapters feature down below
now you might notice that her accent is
a little bit special
that's because sia comes from australia
but she's been living in the united
states for so long that it is really
soft
so you might not even notice that and
finally if you're a really big fan of
sia like i am
then you're not going to want to miss
out on the extra lesson that we have
over on our instagram with another one
of her popular songs
so now let's jump in
thank you we're pals so i have seen
what your face looks like i know what
you look like hal
is another way of saying friend example
we are best pals
ellen is saying that as she is a friend
of sias she already knows what her face
looks like
this interview was made several years
ago and up to this moment
unless you followed her early career
sia's face was a total mystery
i know what you look like but whenever
you perform you
do not like to show your face and i
think people don't understand why so
explain that first
when we talk about someone performing or
someone's performance
we're referring to an activity they do
to entertain people
like singing acting etc well i was just
it's so that i can go to target and buy
a hose if i want to
target is the name of an american hyper
market where you can go purchase
different types of products for your
house
clothes and groceries in this case c is
saying that as people don't know her
face
she can go to the store and buy a hose
which is a tube that you'd use to water
your plants
however by saying this as well as what
follows sia is basically saying in a
humorous way
that she wears her wig in order to avoid
fame and to be able to lead a normal
life
nobody would be following me with a
camera trying to get the shot
sia is talking about the paparazzi here
who tend to chase celebrities in order
to get photos or as she says it
shots so again she is joking that she
could even do something ridiculous and
no one would recognize her
alright so now we will continue with
another interview with skia
where you actually get to see her face
but quickly before we do i want to let
you know that if you are
new here every single week we make fun
lessons just like this one
to help you understand fast speaking
natives just like sia
without getting lost without missing the
jokes and without subtitles
like emil who says that thanks to our
videos and our fluent with friends
course
he has greatly improved his english
vocabulary pronunciation
and even grammar and you will too it's
really simple hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below so you don't
miss a single one
of our new lessons all right so sia is
actually trying her hand at
film she recently directed a movie
called music which is coming out in
2021.
there's a magical little girl your
sister
all she's got now is you
she can understand everything you are
saying to her and if you are happy
press this very funny troublemaker
she sees the world in a completely
different way from us
music so in this interview she actually
is talking about that
and we'll look at a fascinating part
where she talks about how she actually
became a singer
what about yourself what about putting
yourself in the film
oh me oh well i mean truthfully
when i was little i thought i was gonna
be an actor and then
um i just saw singing in places like
at the bus stop or um when i was
bartending and people would say you've
got a really good voice and then
i ended up in um i think in italy
and i was at a karaoke club and i sang
karaoke and this guy came up to me
afterwards and
he was like hey my name is dj gas um
i really want puchan to want my house
songs and he gave me 50 pounds
and that was i was going to london the
next day and so
um i sang on something that was unlike
anything i would have ever normally done
and then i got up
my cousins who were in england that said
hey there's a
uh open mic night you should go um
and so i went and then in front of the
stage while i was singing
at the
something green oh it was a club in
london that was
just a tiny little club um anyway
um there's this guy running backwards
and forwards in front of the stage going
you're with me you're with me and
afterwards
he was like i'm gonna manage you i'm in
the music industry
they uh kind of showed me to
jamiroquai's management and suddenly i
was a singer
i just i was like oh i'm getting paid to
do this i'm a singer
but amongst friends i do like doing
um you know impressions and whenever i
tell stories i'm storytelling i usually
play the character who's i'm talking to
oh me oh well i mean truthfully
when i was little i thought i was going
to be an actor which of these words is a
synonym of truthful
honest fake deceptive
that's right the adverb truthfully is
used to refer to doing something
honestly and sincerely
she's saying that she truly believed
that she was going to become an
actor did you notice that she said actor
and not
actress although words like this are
rare this one can be used to refer to
both male
and female actors when i was bartending
and people would say you've got a really
good voice and then
a bartender works serving drinks at a
bar before becoming a superstar sia had
this job
and i was at a karaoke club and i sang
karaoke and this guy came up to me
afterwards and
he was like hey my name's dj guess the
word
afterwards is an interesting one to add
to your everyday vocabulary
it is used as a way of referring to a
later time
and would be most honored if you could
join me i don't think so i think i
should be getting home
i promise you it'll be like nothing
you've ever seen
afterwards you'll return home safely
see is saying that after seeing karaoke
a dj came up to her because he was
interested in working with her after
listening to her sing
i really want to push onto one of my
house songs
here we have a couple excellent examples
of native connected speech
now sia here is imitating a foreign
accent but actually does some common
sound morphing
first off how did she say put you let's
listen again
i really want to push onto one of my
house songs did you catch that
she didn't say put you she said put you
this is because often when we have a t
followed by a y
sound it morphs to a ch sound
but falling for you was my
mistake i put you
on top
and then she did something interesting
with one of
she didn't say these two words clearly
like one of
she reduced the of to uh which natives
do all the time
then she connected it to one so it
sounds like wanna
one of these
i've watched his wildest dreams come
true and not one of them
involving you just watch my wildest
dreams come true
not one of them
[Music]
by the way if you find it confusing when
natives speak like this then i highly
recommend you try our three-part master
class
now in addition to tips for how to learn
vocabulary
and understand the jokes we will teach
you how to understand natives when we
speak really fast
and connect our speech just like you've
seen here it's absolutely free
and you can learn more and sign up by
clicking up here or down the description
below
and then i got up my cousins who are in
england that
said hey there's a open mic night you
should go
what do you think mike means mike is a
shortening of the word
microphone that we use all the time in
english so an
open mic night is a live show in which
any audience members can perform on
stage
this is quite common and both
professionals and amateurs participate
oh it was a club in london that was just
a tiny little club
what's another word we could use instead
of this
minuscule we
trick question all these actually mean
the same thing
and that is something really small
example
i live in a tiny apartment the bedroom
is especially minuscule and the bed
barely fits
there's this guy running backwards and
forwards in front of the stage going
you're with me you're with me backwards
and
forwards are antonyms that is words that
have opposite meanings
if someone is running forwards it means
that they are running straight
however if someone is running backwards
that means that they are running in the
direction of their back
in reverse however when put together it
means that someone is going all over the
place
you might also hear back and forth do i
really belong in this game i pondered i
just want to play my part should i make
waves or not so back and forth on my
brain the tug of war wages on
and i can still see it all in my head
back and forth from new york sneaking in
your bed
and afterwards he was like i'm gonna
manage you i'm in the music industry
every singer in the music industry needs
a manager that is a person responsible
for controlling and administering their
business
amongst friends i do like doing um
you know impressions and whenever i tell
stories i am storytelling i usually
play the character who i'm talking to
an impression is the act of performing
an imitation of a person in order to
entertain
another singer that is really good at
musical impressions is ariana grande
let's see how well she imitates other
singers all right so britney spears who
we all know
and mary had a little lamb
[Music]
if you love ariana we have a couple of
lessons with her
you can check that out in the
description after you finish this lesson
okay and now let's learn with two great
songs by her let's start with elastic
heart
and did you know it's music video stars
actor shia labeouf
[Music]
[Applause]
break yeah
[Music]
is
this is a very popular expression you
can use it to refer to a
victory defeat tie
there can only be
[Music]
if this seems familiar to you maybe it's
because you've heard the queen song of
the same name
another one bites the dust
[Music]
we've linked a lesson with this and two
more queen songs in the description
in case you want to check that out
[Music]
this term is used in the military to
refer to the act of taking control of a
foreign land or people by force
however in cases like this one this word
is used figuratively to say that you
successfully deal with something
so if you conquer love you are
successful in your romantic
[Music]
relationships
here sia continues using military words
to refer to things related to love
a weapon is any object used in a fight
or war in order to generate damage
some examples of weapons are guns bombs
and knives
[Music]
with this short phrase you can learn a
lot about american stress and
pronunciation
in this utterance she only stresses
these words i
wanted bad the rest of the words reduce
furthermore we can hear a couple
examples of connected speech
first the function word and hooks to the
pronoun i
and she drops the d and i next
when we have an nt in english we often
drop the t
sound for example i can eat that
internet
international so instead of
i wanted it we can hear that it's
[Music]
let's hear it again fast and slow
a red flag is a common sign used to warn
of danger
example you shouldn't swim in the sea
today the lifeguard hung a red flag
we can also use this figuratively there
were a lot of red flags but we hired him
anyway
now we're regretting it
this phrase means to completely defeat
[Music]
someone
still try and break me
something thick has large distance
between sides
example old houses often have thick
walls
now as a figurative expression if
someone has thick skin
then they are not easily hurt
emotionally so this person would not be
so sensitive for example
to insults or criticism example
feel free to offer her feedback she's
thick skin so she can handle it
and something elastic has the ability to
stretch and return to its original size
for example you might know elastigirl
from the incredibles
[Music]
a blade is the sharp cutting edge of a
knife or weapon
when a blade is sharp it can cut things
very easily
this is a rubber band you may know that
a rubber band is very elastic
but if you stretch it too much it'll
break
when something breaks suddenly and
completely it snaps
the phrasal verb fall apart works as a
synonym for break
so it is used to say that someone feels
completely defeated
hey do you love learning english with
music then i highly recommend that next
you check out this lesson that we made
with shakira
you'll learn english with some of her
songs and we'll also show you how she
got such exceptional english
and remember you can learn english with
another one of sia's hit songs
chandelier exclusively over on our
instagram so be sure to check that out
and now let's wrap up this lesson with a
recent performance of one asia's most
recent songs in the billboard music
awards
[Music]
here i watch the news on tv
abandon myself daily i have sons
and i love them so dearly
[Music]
i want to leave you
if you say that something matters you
mean that this thing is important
or significant by the way in these two
verses we had two
great examples of sound morphing let's
listen to them again
i want my life to matter
if you watch our lessons then you might
be able to recognize this one
when we have a t sound between two vowel
sounds it morphs into a soft d
sound so seo doesn't say better and
matter she says better and matter
this type of sound morphing is called an
american t even though sia is australian
let's look at a couple more examples
it's not always easy and sometimes life
can be
deceiving i'll tell you one thing
is so much better when we're together
yeah so much better when we
and nothing else
if you have a purpose to do something
you have a reason for doing it
or in a deeper sense a reason to exist
example
he learned chinese for the express
purpose of starting a business there
the purpose's life was to help others
abandon is a word used to say that you
leave behind or give up on something
here c is saying that she abandons
herself daily
so by saying this she means that she
doesn't take care of herself
i have sons and i love him
[Music]
this is a way of saying that you feel
lots of affection towards someone in
this case
she is saying that she loves her kids
very much
thank you we're pals so i have seen
what your face looks like i know what
you look like but whenever you perform
you do not like to show your face and i
think people
don't understand why so explain that
first well i was just it's so that i can
go to target
and buy a hose if i want to and
or if i'm in very in need of a restroom
and i can't
find one i could go by the side of the
road
nobody would be following me with a
camera trying to get the shot
what about yourself what about putting
yourself in the film
oh me oh well i mean truthfully
when i was little i thought i was gonna
be an actor and then um
i just saw singing in places like
at the bus stop or um when i was
bartending and people would say you've
got a really good voice and then
i ended up in um i think in italy
and i was at a karaoke club and i sang
karaoke and this guy came up to me
afterwards and
he was like hey my name is dj guess um
i really want to push onto one of my
house songs and he gave me 50 pounds
and that was i was going to london the
next day and so
um i sang on something that was unlike
anything i would have ever normally done
and then i got up
my cousins who were in england that said
hey there's a
open mic night you should go um
and so i went and then in front of the
stage while i was singing
at the oh
something green oh it was a club in
london that was
just a tiny little club um anyway
um there's this guy running backwards
and forwards in front of the stage going
you're with me you're with me and
afterwards
he was like i'm going to manage you i'm
in the music industry
they uh kind of showed me to jimmykai's
management
and suddenly i was a singer i just i was
like oh i'm getting paid to do this so
i'm a singer
but amongst friends i do like doing
you know impressions
then whenever i tell stories i am
storytelling i usually
play the character who's i'm talking to
[Music]
to fight this yeah without weapons
bites
[Music]
is
heart
[Music]
here i watch the news
on tv abandon myself
daily i have sons and i love them
so dearly
[Music]
and keep on my body